of these people are literally  um a fraction of the size of the  apocalyptic and so am I as I'm really  small so like these movements and then  there's a couple people that their  movements were way above last week I  noticed they're they're moving on some  other plane they're they're up here  and they're  their stuff isn't just this  these big movements like anything  they're doing to Mark or me right now  I'll just go like that and like  and like  some about my heart  and some about his  a lot of things this this area but like  apocalyptic it has something to do with  my toes and I know somebody's moved my  toes somewhere so people would get a  hold of those